what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to explain
how aaron jaeger went from looking like
this at the end of attack on titan
season 3 to looking like this during the
early episodes of the final season
a lot of comments on my last video were
asking me why aaron's leg hasn't healed
yet
and why he's in mali in the first place
so i just thought i'd address those
questions
for anime only watches it should be okay
for you to watch this video
as i will not be giving away any major
spoilers or plot twists but still
watch at your own risk don't forget to
sub for more attack on titan videos like
this
and be sure to hit that like button as
well as it will help other people find
this video
okay so at the end of season 3 we saw
that aaron finally made it to the ocean
after all those years
but he was left with a feeling of
dissatisfaction upon arriving at the sea
everything looked just like it did in
grisha's memories
which confirmed to eren that all the
violence against eldians that he'd seen
in those memories was entirely accurate
beyond the sea was not the freedom that
eren wanted
but instead it was just enemies who
wanted to exterminate people on the
island
that season ended with eren asking if
aliens would be free if they killed
their enemies on the other side of the
ocean which kind of gives you an
indication of where his mind is
at in the four years between that moment
and this moment
a lot of changes have happened to aaron
as he's formulated a way to ensure the
survival
of aliens on the island they knew that
mali would not leave them alone
and as commander mcgath revealed during
episode 2 of season 4
marley had sent 32 scout ships to
paradise island
during the time skip aaron realized that
it would be impossible
for the island to make allies with other
countries because you know to the rest
of the world
their hatred for the island is what
brings them together
as a result aaron came up with a plan to
stop the hatred of people on the island
but he mostly kept the plan to himself
and only told a couple of people
during the time skip aaron made his way
to mali as we know
and he knew that this would be the
beginning of his plan to save the island
from the rest of the world
in episode 2 of the final season we saw
aaron on the mainland
observing reiner and the warrior
candidates from a distance
now i'm sure you're probably wondering
why aaron has an eye patch
and also why he only has one leg so
brace yourself for the spoilers on how
that happened
in an attempt to blend in with the
injured soldiers of liberio
aaron cut off his own leg with a knife
and then proceeded to gouge out his eye
by thrusting in a bullet with his bare
hands you could say a lot of things
about eren
but one thing you cannot tell me is that
he's not dedicated i mean this man will
literally do anything for his people
the reason aaron's leg hasn't healed yet
is because he's willingly choosing not
to do so
and we previously saw right into
something similar during season 2.
rhino's arm was injured for a period of
time but he only decided to heal it once
he was ready to reveal his identity
as the armored titan this proves that
titan shifters can choose when they want
to heal their injuries
which as we can see is very useful for
infiltration
in terms of the other differences in
aaron's appearance his stubble makes him
look a lot like his father
which is just a consequence of him
growing up in between seasons 3 and 4.
anyway if you haven't seen it already be
sure to check out my breakdowns of
episodes 2 and 3 of the final season
as i talk about things that you might
have missed during those episodes
be sure to like this video if you liked
it and until the next one
peace out